alex you were cut off uh briefly but
those passengers uh still leaving the
aircraft
yeah they're starting to disembark now
jonathan it's my understanding too that
we are actually expecting a statement
imminently from the british foreign
secretary dominic raab i think i was
also i don't know whether you caught me
i was stressing this is not a commercial
flight it is a chartered flight that's
been laid on by the qatari government
now i think the big question uh for many
people and i i just caught dominic
touching on it there is that there are
still plenty of uh people who are inside
afghanistan who are facing danger who
need to get out how easy will it be for
that to happen now the exact mechanics
of how people manage to get on this
flight
is um difficult uh to say
at this stage but certainly it's by
invitation
is by invitation
rather than uh you just turn up at the
airport now obviously some of these uh
these pictures that we're showing you
are quite um are quite sensitive
so some of the people here the they have
families are still there and they are
obviously vulnerable people so we need
to be very careful of what we show you
uh which is why we are going to which is
why we're going to push the camera back
and not focus too closely
on the uh the people coming off uh this
flight at the moment but it has been a a
tremendously uh difficult ordeal for
these people many of them desperately
frightened stuck inside the country not
knowing how they were
going to get out but of course some have
managed to get out and got aboard this
flight
about 13 we understand in terms of the
brits
but unfortunately there are still people
trapped inside the country the question
tonight of course is how are those
people going to get out
and dominic uh what actually happens to
these people now that they've
disembarked the aircraft
what are the logistics in terms of of
where they go how they're looked after
not entirely sure actually if if they're
foreign nationals if they're amongst the
ukrainians americans british canadians
and germans then presumably they um
after i imagine some kind of debriefing
by their national authorities will be
allowed to go on their way um if they're
afghan nationals who have uh legitimate
legitimate travel papers um and they're
they're traveling because they feel
vulnerable because of their connection
either as translators or people who've
helped and assisted the brits or the
americans during their time in
afghanistan they feel they have to get
out for their own safety
and you know they've been terrified in
the 10 days since
been unable to get out unlike many of
their their colleagues for them there's
a process i think of working out where
they're going to go next what kind of
assistance they will get from whichever
country or government is effectively
adopting them or sponsoring them so
there is a process they'll have to go
through um and you know it's it's a
process i think that will then be
followed by further flight so we're not
really sure as to how many flights are
likely to be what they're saying at the
moment is this is just a test it's not
the first of many and i think the the
reason for that is that they're not
trying to raise hopes too much they're
not managing ex they are managing
expectations i think they it's it's a
flight by flight basis because you know
it was a question as to whether this
flight could take off given the
situation in afghanistan and i think
they will try to see now how many more
flights it can lead to i mean we are
being told another 200 people they are
hoping to get another 200 people out for
the next 24 to 48 hours
but we'll have to see how how
successfully that that happens